Trey Wingo how are you Trey Goodrich how
are you buddy are you feeling I'm okay
you know like with Lana your current are
you burnt like LeBron I'm a I'm a little
burnt but I'm ready to roll
it is funny though just here in the
conversation as on hold
it's amazing how how many people parse
everything that everyone says these days
in listening to that answer like I'm
with you someone asked them a questions
like can I just deal with this today and
then worry about that Tuesday it is
amazing how everyone dives into every
single syllable sometimes with this kid
and they and they want to hear what they
want to hear instead of what's actually
being said and I think Trey part of
LeBrons greatness part of the metric in
coming up with that is that everything
he has said has been parsed since the
minute he played high school basketball
he has been part and parcel of the 24/7
365 sports cable split screen at the
topic bar hashtag argument culture as
well as sports talk radio Twitter
Instagram he is I mean he he's been
every movement and every syllable he
said has been parsed forever and he's
and he's still been able to do what he's
been able to do I mean you know look to
me it's like great just like
confirmation bias okay about a draftee
if you see if you feel a certain way
about a player then you'll find
something that you don't like or like
about him to validate your opinion and
and if people are like criticizing
LeBron for playing what 43 minutes
scoring 45 points but the second time in
a game 7 which has never been done
before in a series in which he won
basically by himself when for the first
time ever and you want to playoff series
for no other teammate in any of the
other seven games had at least 20 points
one time and he led them incomplete let
them in assists rebounds and points in
entire playoff series for the 20th time
20th time in a playoff series and you
you have problems with him I think I
think you need a hug
Trey Wingo here on the Rich Eisen show
at what point at what point do you get a
little loopy on the drafts at Trey at
what point oh yeah I think you and I
both the same way somewhere in the in
the middle of day three you start
forgetting where you are and what time
it is and yeah then you snap it would
you say focus focus yes it's always the
middle of day three for me yeah it is
like around round six I was just
explaining in the prior offers before
you were called her on hold Bill Smith
the researcher who's in my here the
entire time of our crack research staff
he gets him area because I had a trade I
want to I want to tell you about and I'm
like okay if it's not for Tom Brady I
don't want to hear a word out of your
mouth that's it yeah there's a certain
point well now we were at well you guys
were outside on Saturday right yeah no
yeah we were outside too and then
halfway through the day the sun turned
and went from being a very nice
comfortable day to being in a blast
furnace mm-hmm
which which is fine which by the way was
much better than two years ago in
Chicago when it was 39 degrees at
sideways right if we were outside but at
some point I mean that the the
dry-cleaning bills of the suits is going
to be very high this year do you argue
in mail no same way that Mike and I
sometimes you know what we get our
nerves frayed a little bit you and Mel
going oh look there's there's no there's
no way around that you know and that for
me and for us mostly it's Mel and Todd
but sometimes get going right but I'll
jump in the fray sometimes but yeah look
and people like oh wow you guys are
really like each other I'm like no it's
like anything else if you're with
someone for 24 hours today eventually
they're going to do something and you're
going to do something that is going to
rub you the wrong way and that's just
the way it is oh yeah my Twitter
timeline blows off because I've stay off
of Twitter rounds one and two and three
we're not around round three is when I
start taking a look a little peek at
mentions I know and I have no problem
looking at mentions you know I've always
mentioned this to Joe Buck he's like how
the hell are you watching anything you
know on your mentions live and and Dan
Patrick said the same thing to me once
and he's not even on Twitter that he
wouldn't do it but I don't mind
in it and I see every now and then when
Mayock and I start arguing with each
other they think we hate each other I'm
like no he's from Philadelphia that's
what I say he's from Delhi I'm from New
York this way we talk you do anything
long enough with another person you're
going to have friction that doesn't mean
you don't like the other person that
just means eventually humans disagree so
yeah no issues what was your favorite
moment of the draft Trey well it's hard
to go away from this she keeps a keen
Griffon story and that was that was
really something look at the first ten
minutes were just crazy the whole thing
I mean you know we'd never had four
quarterbacks go on the top ten five
quarterbacks in the first round for the
third time ever made the whole whole
Thursday night thing was electric and
one of my personal favorites for me was
when Connor Williams was drafted by the
Cowboys in the second Russian if he grew
up 20 minutes outside of there and you
know his story was well conical than
that great essay he wrote for you guys
on an assault calm and that was a
victory for anyone that's been you know
picked on persecuted alienated left
alone abused and you know felt inferior
in their life as a kid and a lot of us
have been there to see him have that
moment was really pretty cool yeah a
stutterer and you know it's diff it's
difficult to comprehend that somebody of
his size when he was that big he was a
big kid a stutterer and he was picked on
and he was bullied and then he goes to
Texas and he's drafted by the Cowboys
and it really was crying and it really
was an incredible moment that he gets to
stay home in Dallas for the Cowboys and
it's you know a journey that's what I
said at the top with Shiki Matt a
journey completed you know and obviously
there's still much more to go but hard
work hard determination
stick-to-itiveness it pays off and in a
dream realized on live television it is
pretty neat it really is incredible
that's so much fun
rich I mean that's a whole thing to me
it's telling these kids stories I mean I
think people look at them as draftees
and they think of them as products like
hey I'm gonna go get this thing at the
Apple store it's gonna make my computer
run faster you know they seem to think
of them that way they're not widgets
they're human beings
and they all have these things that have
gotten to where they are by the
sidenote I I'm sure you notice this as
well the first round was flying I mean
the pics were coming in fast and furious
yes and then we got to the Cowboys pic
at 19 and lo and bold if the brakes
didn't just get pumped and suddenly they
were there soaking up that moment
perfect important I know there's a some
teams I think you're just you know I
mean the Giants threw in there picked
for will Hernandez within 30 seconds at
the top of the second round there's
another team's will just milk the clock
because they know that maybe they're the
war room cam you know our Honda war room
cam was showing some teams Jerry Jones I
think he knows exactly where the cameras
but another thing to that's great about
the draft tray is that that Connor
Williams moment happened after the
Eagles traded up right in front or to
take the tight end that everybody
thought the Cowboys were interested in
named Dallas and David Akers gets up and
returns fire for Philly in Dallas to try
and match the Drew Pearson moment in
Philadelphia the year before I mean that
was intense
yeah draft Hall time that was a couple
things that was a savage move by Hallie
Rosamond the GM of the Eagles just to
jump the Cowboys to do it and and on the
david akers thing it was great but let's
be honest what the old line you don't
bring your gun don't bring a knife to a
gunfight oh don't hurt ray do not bash
kickers do not it's the way David
sounded okay he sounded like he was
getting into his first r-rated movie be
careful you work for Disney trig and
that Mouse didn't just like him come on
now I where I was a former eagle and I
was like all right that's enough quick
you know bring somebody like that don't
they
I thought you know well I heard that
they were gonna bring out they were
gonna bring out jason kelsey in full
mummer's parade on thursday night but
that somehow got scuttled overnight on
thursday night i don't know what
happened
maybe the howie Roseman it's like I'll
save you airfare we're not picking
round one
and they trade it out for Lamar Jackson
what do you know about Trey what do you
know what are you hearing about jason
witten within your building
I mean Moore's all over this story but
what are you what are you hearing about
it I'm hearing what Witten's hearing I'm
hearing what more cheering basically are
hearing from pork is all like to tell
you funny story though I will tell you
this you know the riches you will know
as well like anyone else that does this
you have to time a certain certain
things just right
including bathroom breaks and at one
point I was running to get one last
bathroom breaking for at the start of
the draft and we have our green room
back there were you and I took our
picture we always do that every year yes
borac FLOTUS started the draft and I'm
walking going to you know use the
bathroom in our green room and there's a
guard outside the door that says hey you
can't you can't go in there like what do
you mean I can't go in there show my
badge I open up and lo and behold Jason
wouldn't sit there having a few
conversations I'm like okay I get it
good good to see you guys moving on and
that's all I know
that's all I know at this point with
brass or Jerry Jones or was he going
number one in blue people okay well
people the green room I see okay gotcha
very good all right so trait fun stuff I
really appreciate you calling in you
take care of yourself okay we'll chat
rich always good to see you I'm always
fun to have a good time with don't draft
weekend will talk to us about it you got
it Trey Wingo coast of Golic and Wingo
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience